[Musik]
hey leute heute eine ganz spontane kiste
haben soll ich habe richtig durst und
haben uns überlegt wir zeigen euch jetzt
ein rezept das ist ein cocktail
alkoholfrei der schmeckt wie soli ruhig
liebe so leo als im sommer gibt ganz
ehrlich zu mein erster weil es immer mal
wandel und meine zweite ist immer das
soleo als was sagst du auch nicht warum
egal aber süß ich sage euch jetzt wie er
1 1 ist es schließlich fertig also ein
getränk das wie das so lehrreich
schmeckt ich habe jetzt hier schon mal
was vorbereitet ich zeige euch ganz easy
wir diesen zucker rand her bekommt und
dafür nehmt ihr euch ganz einfach ein
glas gibt es hier in eine kleine schale
mit wasser und dann direkt in das braune
zucker
[Musik]
und dann sieht es so aus
und da gebe ich jetzt auch noch meine
riesen eiskugel rein das ist die hier
die kennt ihr schon aus dem anderen
cocktail video verlinkt ich euch
natürlich in die infobox und jetzt
müssen wir uns ganz einfach vier zutaten
zusammen und zwar hier einmal
orangensaft ich habe ich maracuja nektar
ist gebe ich direkt mit dazu wobei ich
orangensaft immer etwas mehr habe als
maracuja nektar dann ganz es entweder
ganz wichtig vanille extrakt ihr könntet
auch vanillezucker nehmen aber der lässt
sich nicht so gut auf und einem spritzer
zitronensaft mehr nicht das ist alles
sondern wo ich das oben dann ist es auch
schon fertig so und das wollen wir jetzt
hier einfach ein dann können wir auch
schon genießen
[Musik]
und das war es auch schon jetzt noch mit
ein bisschen minze dekorieren das gibt's
ja auch noch mal so ein bisschen
geschmack ab und dann könnt ihr euer
solero cocktail genießen
karibisch ja also ich sag dir mal was
wir brauchen gar nicht mehr im urlaub
fliegen wir machen uns jetzt einfach
immer diesen cocktail oder um genau ein
boom gang cocktail als nächstes schreibe
es in die kommentare ich glaube der
schmeckt dann sehr künstlich aber
irgendwie habe ich dann mal lust drauf
du deiner begrüße ja gute idee wenn man
die eiskugeln dann auf lutscht und
fertig hat dann kann man das
kaugummikauen cool machen wir
betriebsbereit
ok ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen hoffe es schmeckt
euch genauso gut wie uns ist immer total
und ja das war ein kurzes knackiges
video wenn ihr mehr solcher knackigen
videos sehen möchte den schreibt auf
jeden fall auch rein und dann freuen wir
uns wenn ihr auch beim nächsten mal
wieder einschaltet einen deutschen nicht
vergessen und ein abo genau da lassen
und dann ist demnächst blickes kitchen
jack's umgang
[Musik]